i love working with this man and getting
to call this man a friend and having him
call into the show stanford football
head coach david shaw back on the rich
island show how are you coach
i'm great really excited to be on the
drop the glove show i think my wife is
more excited
that i'm on the show with the star of
when harry met sally
oh okay you know what i don't know
there's so many ways that i could go and
talk to billy crystal
i want maybe like his best andre the
giant story from the princess bride
you know i mean that wouldn't be a bad
way to go he's also he also spoke at
muhammad ali's memorial because he knew
muhammad ali for decades
that guys and one of the best muhammad
ali impersonators ever of all time
agreed the voice was just perfect agreed
well
um a coach uh david it was great having
you uh
part of the network coverage again and
and and us all hanging out
um did you have a sense the first night
again you know you're
you're a professional deep down uh did
you have a sense
because pep hamilton was on the staff in
houston and and
dave that davis mills would wind up
there night too was there any indication
on your dashboard that that light was
blinking
i i wasn't sure um we had had
conversations really through the years
about davis um
and he had touched base with us this
week i thought a lot of people
thought he was going to go in the second
so i heard from multiple people hey if
he finds his way to the third
like we think this is a guy that has a
chance to be an nfl starter we're going
to take them
it just happened to be the the texans
were first in line but
was was pep uh in any way shape or form
um informing the decision that wound up
with houston
jumping on him uh not sure
not sure they didn't let me know about
their communications in the building but
i did touch base with pep earlier in the
day uh
just to get some final have a final
communication about them
and i know i know they thought highly of
them um
like everybody else would love would be
great if we played six more games to get
a full season in
right um but they like what they saw
okay so let's dive into this as well
because you know how
important it is to be born into the nfl
properly
right with an organization that's stable
uh with a head coach who has you know um
not only security but also experience
and then there's a clearer path to
succeed
and that there's not any drama around my
gosh
is davis mills in a uh a spot that is
rife with all sorts of potential
hiccups pitfalls roadblocks or maybe
monster opportunity
what what's your conversation with him
about as he heads to houston
right now oh well we had the
conversation the other night
and i feel great about davis davis has a
calming
effect on people and on an offense
so i think as far as the whatever
influence he can have
early on he is a stabilizing person
uh very similar to me honestly
personality wise
not a lot of highs not a lot of lows
very workmanlike
very confident he'll handle this
situation the right way he'll say the
right things
and if he has the opportunity to compete
for the job he'll compete for it
i think he's got a chance to win it if
he does and if he does
he'll go out there and play well so you
won't have i don't think the stock
market
up and down that typically you'll have
in a rookie because he is such a stable
stable person but i mean talk about the
situation he could find himself in i
mean let's let's
let's walk through it he could find
himself in he could find himself in a
situation where he's starting
week one um because he's won the job
uh because deshaun watson's long gone or
he starts week one because he's won the
job
because deshawn watson is holding out or
he's backing up to rod taylor and then
eventually gets the job
once it's time for this kid to be the
successor to deshaun watson
all of them are rife with their own
pressures
and i i'm wondering how you think and
how you would counsel him to handle all
this with the time that you obviously
had in the nfl as well
as all the years of uh your wisened
experience in college
uh well you know we've talked through
the years about different quarterbacks
and
what you said at the beginning is very
very uh very true
about you'd love to go into the most
stable
opportunity environment
but you don't always get that so in
order to go into a situation with so
much uncertainty
one of the things that's most important
is your personality
and your your internal fortitude right
so for this situation could be
just absolutely terrible for somebody
who needs that structure
um and i'm just gonna be very
self-serving davis mills is a stanford
man
he's smart he is tough he's a leader uh
and he's gonna be able to handle
whatever's thrown his way and all those
possibilities he and i talked about all
those possibilities
but the bottom line he's gonna show up
every single day the guys are gonna be
able to trust him they're gonna know
that he's to know what to do he's going
to study he's going to prepare
and we'll give the opportunity he's
going to go perform so with all the
uncertainty around him
one of the things that won't be
uncertain will be davis mills
so you think he's made for this moment
in a way that you know obviously
somebody coming out of college you know
doesn't usually expect a moment like
this i'm sure his dreams
uh of beginning in the nfl uh have been
there since day one but
it's not like there's the cards are
stacked against him but there is a this
is a unique set of circumstances you
think he's made for
for the moment as best anyone can i i'm
a firm believer
and who rose regardless of anybody's
religious affiliation
like often like you end up being the
place where you're supposed to be
right so a lot of his life
i'm sure i mean through difficulty two
knee surgeries
bouncing back uh quarterback
competitions all kinds of things going
crazy covet situation we're going to
play we're not going to play we are
going to play but it's going to be
shortened season oh by the way kid
first game of the year national tv now
you have a false positive so you can't
play
like he's been through so much that now
he's like hey this is my this is my lot
last follow me throw me in a difficult
situation
give me difficult circumstances and then
i'm gonna go perform so to a certain
degree i agree with what you just said
which is
man if there's anybody that you would
want to be in a situation like this
you want to have the smartest toughest
most grounded individual
to be able to handle this situation and
that's who davis mills is
stanford university head football coach
four-time pac-12 coach of the year and
my colleague on first night of the nfl
draft david shaw here
on the rich eisen show now that we're uh
tonight one week removed from
the first round of the draft um who's in
the best situation
out of any of the first round
quarterbacks drafted
based on i guess continuing on our
conversation about
spot stability scheme
everything that was uh that a first
round pick wants to be born into in the
nfl which one do you like the most
that's such a hard one for me because
there's two guys that
and to me it's the first two
quarterbacks um
trevor lawrence is walking into a
situation where
the team is not good or they weren't
good last year
by their record but when you watched the
film
they really weren't that bad right so
now you've got a bad record
but a decent team and now you take the
best player in the draft my best
quarterbacks to come out a long time
a really good running back uh a good old
stanford tackle
you've got two really really smart
offensive coordinator type minds that
work together
that are they're going to be sound
they're going to be smart you've got
uh urban meyer who in my opinion is not
just a college coach
yeah love him or hate him urban meyer is
an organizational thinker
so he's a systematic human being i've
gotten the urban over the last 10 years
very systematic very well thought out so
they're putting together something there
that is going to be dependable and
consistent
and now you just win five of those close
games that they lost last year
and then boom now you're you're on the
borderline of being a playoff team
um your your wonderful jets there i
thought joe douglas
did an unbelievable job uh off season
and leading into the draft
same thing you got the quarterback you
got the best interior alignment in the
draft
and you've got a dynamic receiver and
you've got a really good running back
and you've got four of the best players
of their position in the draft
to come and influence uh
once again having a low bar from the
year before
an opportunity not just to win games but
to rejuvenate
a fan base and an organization to say
man now we have a chance to compete i
thought those those two quarterbacks are
in great position
yeah i know and they got that left
tackle last year in beckton um
and and put vera tucker now next to him
and you're you're building something you
can run left and also protect
the kid but i'll i'll be honest here i'm
surprised you didn't include
trey lanson that i know i asked for one
but you went two and and lance
um being in a situation where there's
kyle shanahan a team that traded all the
way up for him he may not get the
ability to start week one in the same
way
that uh that you mentioned lawrence and
and zack wilson but
um i'll give you the floor on that
subject matter
i think he's in a great position i just
know how much he's going to play
um that's that's the only reason why i
thought i chose those other two guys all
these guys are going to be on the field
playing every single snap
right i would love to see trey come in
and play a role in each game because i
think he's got that kind of ability
and you've got a quarterback and jimmy g
two things we know for sure
number one when he's healthy they win
number two when he's hurt they don't
so if we can take five to seven hits a
game off of our starting quarterback
that led us to the super bowl a couple
years ago
hey that's great you've got one of the
best offensive minds in all of football
and kyle shanahan to now play this game
a little bit to where jimmy g hey you're
a guy
we're gonna win games because of you but
guess what we're gonna
we're gonna get some some mileage out of
this young guy that doesn't just take
you off the field
but really allows you to stay healthy
and be there for us hopefully for 16
17 plus games now before i let you go
coach shaw
um you know one of the many reasons why
i just love talking to you and then i
i i'm so lucky to be sitting to your
right uh and you to my left on draft
night is you're you're you're
you're at the center of so much from
your time in the nfl
your time in college you know football
you know the kids you know bright minds
you also know the league
you know the politics you know the ends
you know the outs so with
all that is my setup i do want to ask
you what you think of this whole aaron
rodgers packer situation
just where you're sitting from where
you're sitting from whatever you might
be hearing not to turn you into a news
and information person but you
you hear so much and you also know the
league in the way things go
and also smart players who are know when
they're being managed by management
how do you see this playing out coach
david shaw
i am definitely not an insider right i
know that um
but it's a shame
first of all when this came out
obviously just for the guys getting
drafted that
you know this is just news that uh i
think
deterred a lot of us in our
conversations about should be the
top day of a lot of these guys lives but
you've got one of the top three
quarterbacks in the league
no he can't be rated any anywhere past
number three
you're wasting your time it's a shame
that it's gone this bad
that it looks like it might be
unresolvable
because first of all you need a
quarterback to win
but in order to win the big one you need
a great quarterback
you've got a great one in green bay and
for the relationship to get where it is
for me you have to find a way to resolve
it
you know is it financial is it contract
whatever it is
um and if it's too far gone you still
try to resolve it
we don't play games for a long time now
got plenty of time to try to get this
done
um and uh and i hate to hear you know
firing people i just
that i hate to hear that stuff it's how
can we get to the point where
we can get this all-time multi-pro bowl
hall of fame quarterback to feel like
organization like we are wrapping our
arms around him
and giving what he needs for this small
window that he's got
you know still a small window but their
window is there to go win another
lombardi
yeah that's what this whole thing's
about yeah and just to touch upon one
thing you just said there about firing
people
you know that because we have not heard
this from rogers it's all been
attributed to people supposedly in the
know
about him that um and i'm wondering
if when people say also who are
attributed to be in the know about him
like bob mcginn uh who's been covering
the packers for so long that he's in the
hall of fame
as a writer that there's a two percent
chance of rogers coming back to being
the quarterback of the packers and i'm
wondering if that two percent
is the figure that's being thrown out
there because they
in the rogers camp feel that's the
percentage shot
of the packers giving rogers what he
supposedly wants in the firing of the
general manager
then then i think this is unresolvable i
mean because you know the packers
organization i don't think they would go
that far and the problem with even
having this discussion is we ascribe
truth to
the rumor that rogers is actually
pushing for that which may not be true
that's the one way that i think that
this is potentially if this is all
in fact emma's truth unresolvable
unresolvable
yeah and that would be it'll be very
unfortunate um but we've seen it over
the years
from from jimmy and jerry at dallas the
house cowboys like a lot of things that
for those of us on the outside we're
looking at saying gosh why would they
break it up why would they do the things
that we wouldn't want them to do
or also not in the meeting rooms we're
not on the field we're not
in the organization and sometimes
strong-willed individuals and
perfect circumstances lead to things
that
we none of us would want to see but we
have to
deal with so i guess where would
[Music]
i'll go here with you if you don't mind
where do you think would be a good spot
for him other than green bay
that's the spot i mean in the afc you
know the way this works
throwing something to the other like
what scheme would actually
i mean any scheme would work right
wouldn't they would tailor it to him
if he goes yeah so i think like a
football coach and anybody who doesn't
have a pro bowl quarterback
wants aaron rodgers there is no scheme
that doesn't fit aaron
there's no player group that doesn't fit
aaron there's nothing that doesn't fit
aaron this guy's an all-time
great and you problem it on any
organization you automatically go into
the playoffs
now can you put enough around them to
win so i
that i i put the list as anybody who
doesn't have a great one right now
is talking and saying okay let's make
that phone call
apparently kyle shanahan did it yes
let's make that phone call
just to check and see if we can get this
guy because we will go
from the bottom to the middle from the
middle to the top
because that's how good this guy is
david you're you're you're the best man
uh let's catch up during the summer too
um
again i want to put you on the phone
with my oldest son who says i want to go
to stanford and then we say well have
you done your homework and he goes well
not yet and i'm like okay that's just
not going to happen
so i i might need you you know to rally
my
troops at home in that respect at the
very least but then
as usual just just like the kickers and
partners i'm there for you thank you
thanks again david everybody at nfl
network just raves about the experience
of working with you you should know that
i don't mind sharing that publicly
you're the best thank you
take care rich right back at you that's
david shaw head football coach at
stanford
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here